everything that you said love everything
is uh uh counter entropy goes against
the way
uh the basic physics of the universe so
maybe actually the atoms really don't
like what we're doing they want us to
stop they've been trying really hard to
stop and despite that we somehow uh
started this whole bacteria thing for
for like a billion years and now we're
here I think of it kind of the other way
I don't think there's any purpose to
purposelessness right so so why would
anything be here if we if the drive
weren't towards
creativity right if the drive warrant
towards those subatomic particles not
being nothingness that blips in and out
of existence right like we think is
going on in empty space you know for
light years upon light years right but
is
is there a design either natural or
intentional for
um a schema right a scenario that allows
for the incredibly rare but not
non-existent Eddie pool of counter
entropy where good can happen right
where creativity can happen where
ultimately something can grow something
novel can happen there's no novelty in
the vastness of space even though
there's not nothing there there's
novelty here because I think the the
layers of uh of emergence start stacking
very very very high when we're in the a
place of counter entropy which then
could provide even thoughts about like
good and evil right the idea that
creating that preserving is good right
it's what we build upon it's how we get
to the Eddie pool of counter entropy
right so then destruction is not good
you know what what good comes of
aggression and destruction right you
know unless we're protecting we can
think of of outlying cases but just
think in general concepts right
destruction destroys it brings us
towards a state of entropy towards a
state of nothingness whereas goodness
commonality
um collaboration right
nurturing right brings
novelty it brings new existence into the
universe and I think we don't we don't
think about that we're in the middle of
something so vast and built on top of so
many layers and I think it leads us to
be Cavalier you know with with human
life including often our own
so you think this there's a underlying
creative force of the universe that uh
that might even have a kind of
built-in morality to it where
creating is better than destroying
and then that somehow maps on onto our
society where we kind of try to figure
out what that actually means in terms of
Good and Evil so there that's some
something is there like that but it's
like but it has to be
it's like so nice it's so perfect
because it's rare
is sufficiently rare where we have our
own space like you can like close the
door and it's like I need to be alone
right now as our human civilization to
work on my thing so sufficiently rare
that there's not other alien
civilizations they're just like
constantly knocking on our door
destroying us
um but it still exists that's weird
right right it's so fantastically
improbable yeah that I think we should
be very respectful of it and I think you
said there's a creative force that
values creativity yes things to be well
sure if it's a creative Force right it's
existence its ability to exist and to
create
comes from something other than entropy
right something other than so much
dispersion that there's nothingness
right so so the creative force will
value
the sanctity of things right you know
keeping things together not destroying
things right building novelty including
novelty of knowledge novelty of
sentience I mean it fits with the idea
that we're not nothing that that's
incredibly improbable and that there are
these many many layers of emergence that
we're standing upon and I think it tells
us something that we're not doing
ourselves a service to ignore right it's
not just a jump to saying oh there's a
religious answer to everything he says
no it's saying
science isn't a God either right so if
we if we if we think of science as a
tool and not as an endpoint in and of
itself what is the science telling us
like I remember showing up at medical
school and it really is true I mean I
knew so little about the human body I'd
only been in hospitals to visit people
I'd taken pre-med classes but sort of
intensely at once after I didn't take
any and I was working in business I I
knew next to nothing and and I had this
idea that was so naive in retrospect
that I was going to learn so much right
I was going to answer these questions
because I was going what's going on in
the body what are these organs doing
what are these cells and what I learned
was
there was so much more that was amazing
and mysterious and seemingly impossible
like even how a cell functions right
like what is going on inside of a cell
the transport mechanisms and energy
functions and diffusion functions and
then you can go down to smaller levels
than that but when you come back out and
you say how all those cells make a
kidney it's not
explanatory you know I remember asking
the OB who had delivered my first child
right I was so amazed and I asked him
like what do you think like what do you
know you do this right you're seeing
this life created and you know and his
thought was nothing where I just marvel
you know I mean I get to do this but I
just marvel at it and I think the more
we know
about us the more we respectfully Marvel
and we should do that we should
proactively Marvel at every aspect
at every layer
uh that uh where the novelty emerges
yes we'd be a lot less likely to say hey
I don't like you because of something
whatever it is you know race religion
culture sexuality gender identity
whatever it is you know I want to say I
want rights that you don't have right or
I want what you have right I mean
there's so much of this and I understand
it's driven by scarcity and by human
insecurity and envy and all of these
things that I think could drive us
towards destruction but all of that
recklessness comes from
not having this initial appreciation and
respect that you're referring to and
just marveling at like wow okay we're
here that's amazing let's start with
that